BILL GATESNOW.FOR BEING WITHW.
I REALLY PREACH ITLAD TOALOU>>.
SINCWE LAST SPOKTHORTING ABOUTM
TOPICS.
I WANTED FEEL SOME
BEENISREPO.RT T
YOD MERE
ENDING YOURRS ONLEL,DO IMI
ME IPT WE
END IA SOURCEF
GR SADSS
TI A WKI THEATN RTNERSHIWEG TO
CONTINUE.>>HEID THA
THERE'S GOING TO B A
THAT'S YOUR HO?PERIOD TO I TRK
>> YEAH.
S THINDAE
LPATION BE
ENJOYED OU
TOOF U WORK
WITH LEADERS AND HELP BUILD THE
ORGANIZATISO, YOU KNOW
DEFY THE  R THE FOUNDATION.
>>RE COUPLS
REPORTING THAT ARE OUT THERE IK
MARRIAGEHE NEW YORK TIMES" AND W
STREET JOURNAL BOT IS THATINDA
ERNED ABOUT A RELATIONSHIP YOU S
G
WHEN THAT T WITH LIC, C YOU EXP
ATIONSHIP WITH EPSTEINVE ANYCE
YOU
>>L, CERTAU I D SEVERAERS HIMUA
E SA GETTING
BILLIONS
GLOBALEAROUGH CONTACTS
EMWH
IT LOOKED LIKE A RE THING RENDEE
TO SPEND T, TOILITY OF, YOU
KN
THERE WERE LOTS OF OTHERS AT SA
>> THERE'S BEEN REPOG ABOUT ACEE
OMFT
NA FORTUNETHAT YOUR  EA UNSAFE C
ER, INEV D
Y K
REEC I
YOU KNOW, ATNETO G